let's get to the political bombshell
that exploded today after the
publication of an interview with
Christine Blasi Ford who up until now
had anonymously claimed that Brett
Kavanaugh tried to physically force
himself on her while drunk at a high
school party nearly four decades ago
when he was 17 years old the interview
includes new details and corroboration
in the form of therapist's notes from
six years ago I want to make sure you're
fully informed with all the facts you
need so here's the timeline in July
Christine Blasi Ford wrote to her member
of Congress California Democrat Anna
Eshoo detailing the assault and asking
to remain anonymous congresswoman Eshoo
then forwarded the letter to Senator
Dianne Feinstein the ranking member of
the Senate Judiciary Committee which of
course was handling the Cavanaugh
confirmation
Dianne Feinstein shared the contents of
the letter with a small number of aides
and fellow senators but honored the
request for anonymity neither the
existence of the letter or its contents
were brought up at any stage of the
confirmation process either publicly or
privately on Wednesday last week online
news outlet the intercept published a
story about the letter accusing senator
Feinstein of withholding it the next day
Feinstein still trying to honor the
request for anonymity referred the
matter to the FBI and made that referral
public without revealing its contents
that set off a media firestorm which
resulted in Ronan Farrow from The New
Yorker going public with the allegations
still at that point anonymous ones Brett
Kavanaugh has categorically and
unequivocally denied this allegation and
the Judiciary Committee vote on his
nomination remains scheduled for this
Thursday the letter itself has now been
published Democrats are united in
calling for a delay while this matter is
fully investigated some Republicans
including Lindsey Graham and Jeff Flake
say they want to hear directly from Miss
Ford the alleged victim before moving
forward and now Senator Chuck Grassley
chairman of the Judiciary Committee says
he is actively working on following up
with
both Brett Kavanaugh and Miss Ford
before proceeding with the confirmation
process now those are the facts and
based on what we know now at this point
here's my opinion one none of this
changes the fact that Brett Kavanaugh is
qualified for a seat on the court and
that his judicial philosophy is not only
in line with what Donald Trump promised
in the 26 campaign 2016 campaign but
good for the country too Dianne
Feinstein has been unfairly castigated
in all this it was not her but the
intercept that put this matter in the
public domain three some on the Left
have politicized this in a deeply
disturbing way just look at this
statement from the liberal pro-choice
group narrow quote the charge of sexual
assault against Brett Kavanaugh is
disqualifying and we call on him to
immediately withdraw his nomination for
the Supreme Court the charge an
accusation on its own is disqualifying
imagine if we accepted that as the new
standard anyone could make up anything
about a candidate or nominee that they
oppose politically destroy them
personally and prevent them from public
office our republic depends on good men
and women who love their country and
love their community stepping into the
arena to serve and lead their fellow
citizens this outrageous new standard
that any attack at all any allegation
can end someone's career that is the
true threat to democracy not president
Trump as all these leftists claim this
is quite simply the rule of the mob and
we must not allow it to prevail